يتحدث الشعب البرتغالي عن بلد مثل
البحر
هناك حديث عن بلد به صيادون
تقاليد صيد وتعليب رائعة
البرتغالية لكن تقليدها موجود
احتفظ بهذا المكان وهنا للتشجيع
[أغنية]
يمكن أن يحدث مائة وكرافت أخرى
أنا لا أغلق حتى هذا القصر الطويل ، لقد خلعت الحزام
التاريخ لأنواع علم الوراثة وجعلها عظيمة
بين الساعة 15:00 ثم آخر
من x
إغلاق يريدون ملء اسمي ريكاردو
انضم الي و مهنتي و الماجستير
الحرارة
كل يوم هو التحدي عادة بدون
الضوء حوالي 22 23 ساعة حتى الغد
لمعرفة أكثر أو أقل من 10 11 مشكلة
كما لو كان طائر الدودو في اليوم التالي الماء البارد
من شمال الأطلسي لديه خاص
يجعل هذا الخط قد ج
خصائص فريدة
لدينا على الأرجح الأفضل
الدوري العالمي
أسمي الرأي العمل على هذا
المصنع هنا لمدة 30 و 60 عامًا
خلفية هذا المصنع كانت لك و
رأي عمي مانويل هو أن
عمال المصنع صيانة أ
الأسرة
نحن هنا دائما نفس الشيء
عملية تقليدية منذ عام 1920
تتم العملية برمتها باليد
نحن المصنع الوحيد في البرتغال
عملية أفكار الثقافة عندما يكون هذا هو
أمي يذهبون جميعًا مع القصير
ثم عندما يذهب هذا الخط إلى الثالث
لذلك هناك مساحة زمنية في العمل
كانت مختبئة لأنها تجاوزت العنوان
استدعاء مسح لأستراليا في
هل هناك ثلاث ماكينات فقط تتوقف
خبز البلاد سبايك الدولة المتخصصة
وهذا الوقت بالدولار يصنع علبة
كل شيء هو حقيقة أن دورو ألغي تام
[أغنية]
من الأفضل ألا يكون لديك شقراء لتعرفها
لأولئك المسؤولين عن الميناء هو وسط المدينة
في المركز التاريخي لمدينة بورتو التي نعيش فيها
هنا حوالي 20 نوعًا مختلفًا
البحث عن البرتغالية أكثر تمثيلا
هذا الخط بعد النغمة
لدينا هنا نتحدث عن faro أن
المعمر بالفعل ترتدي أهمية
تسليط الضوء على حقيقة أن لدينا
عرض ما هو درس آخر
نحن نتخذ المستشار البرتغالي
معلما هاما خيانة أنا
للاعتقاد بأن هذا التقليد موجود بالفعل
عائلتي لأربعة أجيال
يمثل الكثير في تاريخ هذا البلد
بالنسبة لي لا يمكن إلا أن يكون فخر كل هذا
العملية التقليدية كلها تعمل معها
أيدي لا إذن من الآلات
هذا مرادف للجودة التي أشعر بها
كل عام على ذلك